[Musique]
et notre invité politique pour cette
émission spéciale c'est alain rousset
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
présidente de la région nouvelle
aquitaine en étant 100 pendant une heure
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la pqr avec le populaire du centre avec
sud ouest a représenté par jefferson des
sports rejoint d'affaires salon joue en
rien de bon jour là où c est avec o2
furent sur tv7
évidemment on commence alain rousset par
la crise sanitaire et les annoncé hier
de jean castex avec finalement un
allègement du confinement très allégée
alors certes noël est préservée mais le
jour de l'an sera sous couvre-feu et le
monde de la culture surtout restent
toujours sous cloche avec pas de
réouverture pour les cinémas pour les
théâtres pour les musées est ce que
c'est des décisions que vous soutenez ce
que ce sont des décisions qui vous
paraissent raisonnables ces décisions
qui me paraissent raisonnables
je crois qu'il faut être très modeste
très modeste à l'égard des conséquences
de cette de cette crise
surtout pour la santé de nos de nos
concitoyens c'est une crise totalement
aberrante
d'une certaine manière et donc il faut
avoir une modestie quand on passe son
temps à critiquer ses choix qui sont
faits ce jeu peut pas soupçonner qu'il
niait qu'il y ait des ppte et de la
mauvaise volonté
je peux m'étonner par contre c'est vrai
je regardais ce que dit françois aymé
dans sud ouest ce matin par rapport la
fermeture des salles de cinéma et en
même temps l'ouverture des galeries
marchandes donc là il y à il ya une
vraie contradiction de même pour les les
stations de ski quand même pour vous je
pense que biya et ya des choses qui sont
paradoxalement très dur pour notamment
pour les cinémas vous allez dans un
cinéma il ya la distance
vous êtes immobiles pendant l'ensemble
de la séance
c'est particulièrement protégés là je
pense que peut-être on aurait pu
lever le pied alors on sait derrière ce
tour de vis du gouvernement il est aussi
des chiffres une reprise de l'épidémie
un début de reprise
les vaccins arrivent quelle confiance
vous faites dans cette stratégie
vaccinale qui se profile elle ne se
profile pas qu'en france c'est une
stratégie vaccinale planétaire avec ce
qu'il faut dire à nos concitoyens une
rapidité de mise au point du ou des
vaccins donc un effort scientifique
considère à moi j'ai confiance et bien
sûr c'est pourtant il ya un doute
aujourd'hui autour de ces vaccins vous
savez vous regrettez que cette
vaccination ne soit pas obligatoire
un peu même si je conçois que c'est un
peu compliqué qu'on n'est pas dans un
modèle chinois mais il aurait fallu
casser obligatoire pour tout le monde
pour vous uniquement pour le personnel
soignant pour les personnes âgées où il
faudrait la rendre obligatoire pour
l'ensemble de la population mais je
pense que progressivement cette
vaccination devra être devra concerner
tout le monde
comme un certain nombre de vaccination
concerne tous les enfants nous avons
tous eu des vaccins quel que soit notre
âge des vaccins obligatoires
quelle confiance vous faites au
gouvernement parce qu'on est dans cette
pandémie depuis le mois de mars
maintenant avec un confinement un
déconfinement art confinement et puis
aujourd'hui un allègement est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous estimez que tout ça
est bien géré je pense comme je regarde
l'allemagne qui est un pays décentralisé
que et pas simplement sur le plan de la
gestion de la crise ce plan de la santé
tout court la vraie crainte c'est qu'à
un moment donné l'hôpital public n'ait
pas été capable de de faire face à cette
pandémie et d'accueillir suffisamment de
malades on voit bien que plus on est
proche de 2 des habitants des
territoires - on peut avoir judoce
régulation budgétaire qu'ils font qu'on
a diminué le nombre de lits
ils font que on a en a pas la capacité
de faire face à ces crises d'autant que
c'est chris ray ce qui se passe sur la
grippe aviaire aujourd'hui en nouvelle
aquitaine avec de ces migrations
d'oiseaux sauvages
là c'est pas des c'est pas des migrants
qu'on peut arrêter ça m'a d'abord pour
les agriculteurs j'ai eu notamment un
ami qui est concerné donc c'est quand
même terrible fait abattre 8500 animaux
mais ce qui est inquiétant c'est pour ça
que j'ai mis en place ce comité
scientifique avec le professeur ma nuit
avec gilles boeuf avec des des gériatres
avec des économistes etc pour se dire
préparant le monde d'après mais ayons
l'éclairage et et scientifiques comme on
l'a fait pour la transition écologique
et le projet neo terrain avec 450
scientifique il est important de
travailler avec ces hommes et ces femmes
qui consacrent leur vie à analyser et
penser ces crises cette crise n est pas
sans conséquences économiques notamment
pour les collectivités
combien cette crise elle a coûté à la
région nouvelle aquitaine je ne peux pas
globaliser je sais que nous chaut plan
de nos recettes
on a perdu entre 100 à 150 millions
d'euros
en tout les régions françaises ont perdu
un milliard 2 et comme en même temps
vous de vous
nous avons fait un effort tous faire
pour nos petites entreprises pour les
associations c'est un différentiel de
plus de 300 millions d'euros donc dont
il s'agit sur le pib de la région
[Musique]
j'ai vu passer un chiffre mais je ne
voudrais pas faire d'erreur ce match ce
matin devant vous je jeux les plus
précisément mais moins que vous avez été
suffisamment soutenu à ce qu'il y ait
suffisamment de diallo était très
impliqué c'était très compliqué
l'observer
on n'est pas en allemagne sur le plan de
la gestion de la puissance publique
c'est souvent les territoires qui
invente des des actions politiques
nouvelles on avait créé un nouvel
aquitaine se croient que c'était en 2004
un dispositif sur le logement étudiant
pour garantir auprès des étudiants le
loyer il dépôt de caution
on m'avait dit ouh là mais ça va tu un
puits sans fond finalement il n'y a pas
eu de 2 il n'y a pas eu de les arbres il
n'y a pas eu de problème particulier
l'état s'était geneviève fioraso c'était
sous le gouvernement
les gouvernements de françois hollande a
repris cette idée
aujourd'hui on a plein de pistes
regarder la ministre jacqueline gourault
hier a fait une annonce devant la presse
quotidienne régionale sur une stratégie
de petites villes
comment de paris peut-on s'occuper des
petites villes comment peut-on mettre en
place le générique
ça fait trois ans nous que nous
travaillons avec des contrats de
territoire avec les petits jill on a
fait des appels à projets va dire qui
vous écoute pas mais non ça veut dire
gouvernement ça veut dire que le l'état
jacobin l'administration centrale veut
gérer en direct s'occuper tout y compris
des pistes cyclables et alors même que
nous avons aujourd'hui un problème avec
les forces de sécurité avaient que le
l'enjeu international de déstabilisation
générale avec on a une justice qui n'a
pas les moyens de son de sa mission
reprenez un domaine je sais pas si vous
vous l'avez lu tête d article assez
incroyable qui sont parues dans le monde
la semaine dernière sur les cartels de
la drogue au mexique sais pas si vous
l'avez vu vous vous y mettez vous avez
vu qu ensuite ont été démantelés en
hollande et en belgique
un certain nombre d' usine de
fabrication de cette drogue
quand on regarde y compris par rapport
au terrorisme ce qui s'est passé pour
les terroristes même souvent ils passent
par la case drogue
ajoutez à ça les réseaux de prostitution
on en connaît à bordeaux est ce qu'il
n'ya pas une action de sécurité de
mettre des moyens auprès des forces de
sécurité les forces de police pour
démanteler tout ça est ce que c'est pas
la priorité pour notre sécurité
c'est difficile à la décentralisation
est pas fait alors on sait quand vous
écoute sincère que l'état
décentralisation lé pa r elle s'est
arrêtée avec un film décentralisation la
décentralisation
ah bah ya eu un phénomène de
recentralisation danser gouvernement
même si je sens le premier ministre et
au gouvernement dans celui de uniquement
de puisqu'un kannad emmanuel macron ou
avant déjà y avait un nombre même de
recentralisation était saoul alors moi
je constate qu'il ya eu des progrès
alors j'étais peut-être un peu plus à la
manoeuvre
en tant que présidente de l'association
des régions de france des crédits
européens qui sont gérés par tous par
les régions des länder les provinces etc
ont été un appui considérable vont
l'être encore demain par rapport à à la
sortie de crise mais c'est s'aider
milliards d'euros pour les agriculteurs
pour la transition écologique pour le
développement de la de la recherche
l'apprentissage a été transférée
complètement
nous avons pu faire une carte
d'apprentissage le gouvernement
d'édouard phi lippe a accepté sous
pression du medef de nous sortir la
responsabilité c'est la première fois
qu'il ya eu un recul sur l'apprentissage
et vous avez vu dans les deux premières
années du gouvernement philippe edouard
philippe eymery alpes et nico venir
inaugurer des cfa que les régions avec
les chambres des métiers ou de commerce
avait bâti un peu tout ça est justement
là où c'est on va parler des dossiers de
votre région et de ses de la région
nouvelle aquitaine
on va aller dans plusieurs villes de
nouvelles aquitaine on va commencer par
la bâillonne bonjour pierre sabatier
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous est le
chef de l' agence du pays parce que pour
sud ouest et vous allez poser une
question à alain rousset sur la lgv
bordeaux espagne
je m'y attendais pas oui monsieur
rousset bonjour bonjour fin août dernier
après les défaillances du xiii en die
paris qui avait provoqué de gros tas
vous relancer l'idée d'une ligne
nouvelle entre bordeaux et hendaye
vous croyez vraiment voir un jour la lgv
au pays basque oui c'est l'intérêt du
pays basque que c'est l'intérêt de la
région
alors j'ai découvert une chose
d'ailleurs assez étonnante jeu j'ai fait
un des visites de jolis visite auprès de
jolis entreprises à captieux à langon et
je me suis aperçu qu autrefois il y
avait une deuxième ligne ferroviaire qui
passait par captieux qui descendait vers
dax donc comme j'aimerais ouvrir les
lignes ferroviaires vous savez c'est pas
ça c'est pas simplement une ligne
nouvelle serre et ouvrir les lignes qui
existait autrefois sur ce projet aux
jeunes et c'est bon qu'on est entre 2030
et 2030 sûr c'est aussi là on a connu
les stop and go 1 ça marche
oui mais c'est une vraie écoute et
personne aujourd'hui ne peut mettre en
cause
de la ligne ferroviaire le succès
populaire de la ligne ferroviaire entre
bordeaux et paris
on va continuer à en parler à jefferson
a avoué pierre savatier face à face à
une autre question mais je l'internet je
termine bien il ya un problème financier
j'espère qu'il pourra être réglée de
telle sorte que l'on ne vienne pas nous
chercher nous collectivités locales
comme on l'a fait pour la première
partie la région crème investi comme la
métropole de bordeaux plus de 300
millions d'euros
deuxièmement il ya un vrai problème
écologique le problème écologique c'est
celui des dix mille camions qui passent
dans les deux sens ce qui engorge
bordeaux et qui polluent taille et tout
le travail qu'on a fait faire par les
scientifiques ont montré que la zone la
plus polluée de la grande région de
l'aquitaine la nouvelle aquitaine c'est
la nationale 10 c'est l'ancienne
nationale 10 n'a double pollution des
pollution par les particules fines du
diesel et pollution aussi par les
microdéchets des pneus c'est dramatique
or aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas
capables parce que la ligne est saturé
notamment entre arcachon et bordeaux et
à la gare saint jean
nous ne sommes pas capables de faire
passer des trains supplémentaires
après il faut effectivement que cette
ligne soit bâti moi mon problème c'est
pas que ça roule à 320 ou à 220
le problème c'est que je puisse pour les
usagers pour les marchands d israël une
classique les mettre sur le train on a
deux et demi pour cent des marchandises
et puis c'est l'europe qui nous le
demandent
c'est l'europe qui nous le demandent il
va y avoir une lgv qui va arriver
d'espagne à la frontière et nous on aura
entre bordeaux et l'espagne entre
bordeaux et toulouse
j'ai lancé il n'est pas encore lancée
aux lancers mais moi je reste très
favorable et je me bats toujours pour ce
projet quand quelles sont vos relations
avec le ministre des transports sur ce
sujet et on a pu lire notamment dans la
presse et dans sud ouest qu il y avait
parfois un peu de tirage de frottement
tout simplement parce qu'on est obligé
de se substituer à l'état alors c'est
pas le ministre des transports mais
obligé de se substituer à l'état pour
rénover les voies et éviter que ferme la
ligne
limoges et brive comme est fermée
aujourd'hui dans son centre la ligne
entre limoges et et et angoulême donc
voilà on va parfois financés sans
relations difficiles alain rousset sur 7
sur ce terrain là ben moi je défends la
région faut savoir ce que veut faire
ministre des transports un jeu je
défends ma région je ne veux pas fermer
d'heuliez
je trouve que le transport ferroviaire
est un transport d'avenir
on est en plus en train de dédier
elysées les trains c'est pour ça que je
veux faire ce ce campus ferroviaire à
saintes et ben justement va y aller
alain rousset ça tombe bien on va aller
on va à la rochelle retrouver pierre
emmanuel charpentier bonjour pierre
emmanuel directeur départemental d
édition de la charente maritime et vous
allez nous parler de ce technicentre
deux centres de ce projet figure en plus
ferro conclu bonjour à la hausse est
effectivement avec roger d'offrir au
campus à saintes
satee est une ville qui est éreinté
depuis plusieurs années par par
licenciement économique à une synchronie
6 à u espère c'est une ville qui a
beaucoup souffert ces dernières années
et donc à l'horizon 2023 vous portez
donc ce projet de faire au campus avec
l'accueil d'étudiants avec l'accueil de
beaucoup d'ingénieurs en recherche et
développement
pouvez vous nous détailler ce projet à
hauteur de 43 millions d'euros si je ne
m'abuse
d'abord il ya la reprise d'une friche
industrielle ensuite c'est pia écoles
d'ingénieurs centre de formation
recherche aussi sur le transport
ferroviaire de demain remotorisation
électrique bio bio fuel
bio carburant hydrogène c'est l'avenir
du ferroviaire qui se joue là d'ailleurs
de la même manière que lorsque j'ai créé
l'aérocampus à la traîne je vous
rappelle en est passé de 9 cents
stagiaires à 83 milles imaginez le le
poids de la formation dans notre pays
aujourd'hui cantonales
quand j'ai lancé cette idée toutes les
entreprises de france et de navarre sont
venus la sncf bien sûr et donc il ya un
potentiel il devrait y avoir
vraisemblablement une partie de l'estaca
qui est une école d'ingénieurs qui qui
vient s'installer en gironde est sûre
sur sainte
donc on a un projet qui qui
manifestement passionne mais qui
entraîne embarque avec lui
entreprises sncf donc ses yeux je suis
très content de ce de ce projet ça va
prendre du temps vous avez l'aérocampus
de la traîne parce qu'il faudra faire
des logements il faudra faire des salles
de cours
il faudra installer tout le numérique et
s'avère que la région va se spécialiser
sur le transport entre l'aérien non plus
été en est une industrie aéronautique 70
mille emplois je vais pas je vais pas
laisser tomber m une fatwa sur le sur
l'aéronautique au moment où on passe à
l'avion vert et où il ya soixante dix
mille familles qui travaillent dans
l'aéronautique il faut quand même
problème de l'emploi il faut quand même
le prendre et le problème de la
technologie du futur il faut le prendre
faut prendre tout ça au sérieux mais le
ferroviaire c'est passionnant
charpentier alors on sait qu'il ya kg et
qui va à nouveau intervenir avec 9 de la
question c'était en terme en termes
d'emplois que combien d'emplois
estimez-vous que ça puisse générer à
terme le problème alors une je peux pas
vous dire comme ça en comparant avec
l'aérocampus au sens propre
in situ 1,50 puissant mais le problème
c'est aussi comment une structure de
formation et de recherche entraîne une
attractivité pour le territoire
c'est à dire derrière derrière le ferro
campus
il y aura des entreprises qui vont venir
s'installer pour des rues motorisé par
exemple les rames ter pour les passer à
l'hydrogène ou pour les passer à
l'électrique c'est les emplois induits
qui sont les plus importants pas
forcément les emplois directs mer c'est
comment on crée en d'autres termes
comment c'est la même chose pour l'école
vétérinaire de limoges comment avec des
projets structurants je retourne un
territoire et et je lui donne pour les
20 ou 30 ans qui viennent un avenir
beaucoup plus passionnant beaucoup plus
intéressant que la crainte que vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure merci beaucoup
pierre-emmanuel charpentier d'avoir été
avec jefferson oui on va rester sur
cette question de la région et de
l'économie finalement est-ce que vos
capacités d'investissement peuvent
résister à cette crise est là où c'est
parce qu'on a vient de parler du ferro
campus à saintes avec plusieurs projets
des ouvertures de lignes ferroviaires
mais vous serez tu mens pour 2021
comment vous présenter le budget 2021
sera un but un budget qui est qui et pas
facile on a eu la chance si vous voulez
c5
ces cinq années d'avoir je crois
correctement géré la région plus que les
les calculs savants calculs
l'endettement de la région en année
qu'il faudrait passer si on arrêtait
tout les investissements de la région
pour rembourser la totalité de la dette
on était quatre années donc l'aquitaine
seul était quasiment à zéro on avait
totalement désendettée la région mais on
a eu l'histoire poitou charentes ou dont
vous souvenez là avec cette crise comme
les autres régions on va passer à dix
années de 2 donc et on va revenir on va
se donner du temps
cinq ans pour ne pas faire du stop and
go pour ne pas mettre le pied sur le
frein de l'investissement c'est le dans
ce budget d'investissement allait
continuer à en verser à huy les grandes
lignes toujours l'économie soutien aux
entreprises ça fait partie
les les lycées rénovation des lycées
parce que derrière les lycées c'est le
sait le bâtiment qui donc vous imaginez
c'est des chiffres d'affaires de
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
les transports on va investir entre 60 à
100 millions d'euros par an pour rénover
les voies ferroviaires ou ou rom
autoriser les trains re motorisés aussi
les 5000 car qu'on fait circuler par
jour moi quand je présente mes otéra et
la transition écologique que c'est pas
simplement pour mettre un pot de fleurs
devant ma fenêtre un ccd choses
concrètes
on me connaît un peu voilà mais elle est
utilisée résume l aquitaine aura les
moyens d'être au rendez-vous de la
relance économique va bien sûr mais on
vient d'eux on avait ajouté
140 millions d'euros en direct pour
accompagner les entreprises
on vient de remettre tout une action
dans ce dans ce domaine là et le budget
qui va augmenter cette année ce sera le
budget du développement économique de
l'accompagnement des entreprises et de
la recherche et de la recherche je tiens
beaucoup
si on veut préparer le monde d'après
oui il faudra faire de la sobriété bien
sûr ça ce sont plutôt les individus mais
aussi des entreprises et mais il faudra
qu'on accompagne les agriculteurs il
faudra qu'on accompagne
il faut qu'on invente prenez un exemple
sur lequel en intra de meubles de se
battre mais c'est passionnant aussi
cette période est à la fois anxiogène
mais passionnante
on est en train de mettre en place un
dispositif sur le nouveau matériel
agricole adapté à l'agroécologie comment
par exemple pour les viticulteurs et
c'est tout grand projet viti rêve
comment pour les agriculteurs les
viticulteurs
on supprime complètement de glyphosate
puis le pesticide
c'est ce qui est en jeu avec le projet
littéraire il faut passer sous les rangs
de vigne or aujourd'hui là où il ya
encore l'utilisation du fusad c'est soul
rnb pas au milieu des mythes
donc il faut qu'on invente la machine
qui fonctionne là dessus et il en est de
même demain
si l'on veut on aura une croissance très
forte de l'agriculture biologique
nous sommes la région où l'agriculture
biologique est le plus le prosperi plus
50 confiante et assorti de glyphosate
vous avez un horizon là où c'est parce
que vous savez que le sujet extrêmement
sensible en veille à vos avions dont je
pense que c'est dans les trois ou cinq
ans donc sa survie valorisante à court
terme il a oui il va y avoir une
interdiction de toute manière je vais y
avoir une interdiction c'est pas tenable
ça a été le souhait du président de la
république mais c'est pato n'a par
contre il faut qu'on réponde aux
impasses des agriculteurs enfin c'est
pas comme ça faut pas lancer cette
malédiction
en dix ans on a tous nos matches
aujourd'hui que nous nous menons avec la
coopération agricole on a signé une
convention néo terre à la coopération
agricole ses 73 % des agriculteurs
- mon souci c'est de massifier la
transition agroécologiques la transition
écologique que ce soit avec les
entreprises que ce choix dans
l'enseignement que ce soit avec
l'agriculture alors aussi on va
poursuivre notre tour de votre région
nouvelle aquitaine inquiet vaste ans
après bayonne est là
[Musique]